now this is our solution first Alice and
Bob agree publicly on a prime modulus
and a generator in this case 17 and 3
then Alice selects a private random
number say 15 and calculates 3 to the
power 15 mod 17 and sends this result
publicly to Bob then Bob selects his
private random number say 13 and
calculates 3 to the power 13 mod 17 and
sends this result publicly to Alice and
now the heart of the trick Alice takes
Bob's public result and raises it to the
power of her private number to obtain
the shared secret which in this case is
10 Bob takes Alice's public result and
raises it to the power of his private
number resulting in the same shared
secret notice they did the same
calculation though it may not look like
it at first consider Alice the 12 she
received from Bob was calculated as 3 to
the power 13 mod 17 so her calculation
was the same as 3 to the power 13 to the
power 15 mod 17 now consider Bob the 6
he received from Alice was calculated as
3 to the power 15 mod 17 so his
calculation was the same as 3 to the
power 15 to the power 13 notice they did
the same calculation with the exponents
in a different order when you flip the
exponent the result doesn't change so
they both calculated 3 raised to the
power of their private numbers without
one of these private numbers 15 or 13
Eve will not be able to find the
solution and this is how it's done
while Eve is stuck grinding away at the
discrete logarithm problem and with
large enough numbers we can say it's
practically impossible for her to break
the encryption in a reasonable amount of
time this solves the key exchange
problem it can be used in conjunction
with a pseudo
generator to encrypt messages between
people who have never met